des rumeurs de confinement de couvre-feu
ont circulé hier soir sur les réseaux
sociaux de nombreuses personnes ont
d'ailleurs pris le train pour fuir la
région parisienne le point dans un tgv
paris montpellier avec notre reporter
david pas
c'est une atmosphère un petit peu
particulière dans les wagons les gens
font à droite et à gauche
il évite de se mettre à côté certains
portent des masques d'autres ont des
écharpes autour du cou personne n'ose
réellement se parler les gens ne se
regarde pas il signor en se comprenant
aussi nous avons tous l'impression
d'être un petit peu dans le même bateau
dans la même galère
ces gens qui étaient à paris qui ont
essayé de partir avant de se retrouver
bloqué parce que je pense que c'est la
crainte de tous les parisiens c'est de
se retrouver bloqués dans des petits
appartements d'être obligé de rester à
paris alors qu'ils n'ont pas de travail
pas d'amis dans sera ce soir il ya
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de gens de
25 à 30 ans les gens qui probablement
son foie de jeunes actifs soit des
étudiants et à paris des universités les
écoles sont fermées donc
on décider probablement de quitter leur
petit appartement parisien pour partir
en province de la haute-vienne sûrement
vivre cette période qui est compliquée
qui est difficile
ailleurs qu'à paris et ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est les regards des gens
n'ont pas l'impression sans se parler de
se comprendre de savoir pourquoi on est
là on est là parce qu'on
parce qu'on essaie d'échapper à paris
quand même et on essaie d'échapper à ce
risque d'enfermement parisien c'est
quand même très particulier de tgv ce
soir parce que les annonces ont été
faites au micro comme d'habitude mais on
nous prévient tout de suite qu'il n'y a
pas de restauration à cause du virus
des bouteilles d'eau ont été placés à
quelques endroits dans ce dans cette
rame il n'y a pas de contrôles pour
éviter les contacts humains et il est
tout de suite annoncé que le il y a
beaucoup de places libres dans ce tgv
est qu on invite les gens à se déplacer
et à se mettre le plus loin possible les
uns des autres
donc il ya une vraie volonté de on
s'écarte